uh joy behar speaking of ridiculous
people on television there's a real
theme to the show today
joy behar and first off joy if you're
watching this
i used to love you i really did joy was
a decent liberal she was very funny
if you watch i mean i'm not that i would
recommend anyone ever watch the view or
go back and watch old episodes but if
you remember
that first season when rosie o'donnell
was on the view this is
gosh this is back how many years ago
what year was the first year that rosie
o'donnell
was on the view this is over 10 years
ago at this point probably like 12 years
ago or so
when rosie was the was the moderator and
joy was just a panelist
i used to watch the view all the time
and elizabeth hasselbeck was on there
she was the conservative at the time
and it was just it really was a good
show it was
it was people talking about politics
that disagreed but they respected each
other it was decent
wow 2006 o'donnell replaced meredith
vieira so
geez 15 years ago was the season i'm
talking about
it really was a good show and they were
they were talking about
uh you know the obama movement which was
sort of just starting and they were
talking about
the iraq war and all of these things
that were important and relevant and
everything else okay
and then they would do a segment on like
how to clean your house or something
then i would tune out but the hot topics
thing was actually pretty good
and joy was decent and i used to live a
block or two away from joy in new york
city
i used to bump into her and her husband
on the street we talk about comedy
i've interviewed her a couple times on
my old sirius xm
show and on some red carpets and things
and she was a decent liberal
but something has happened to the decent
liberals and
almost all of them have gone completely
off the deep end and just freaking lost
their minds again
because trump just broke these people
and i would say if you're a decent
liberal who's not insane at this point
you're a conservative in any event joy
was on the view yesterday
and listen to what she said about my
friend
and journalist true journalist who's
been on the front lines
uncovering what antifa is doing in our
cities andy no let's take a look
the banjo player from the group mumford
and sons
winston marshall announced that he's
leaving the band
after getting blowback for praising a
far right-wing pundit's book
about antifa in a post on medium
martial claims he doesn't want his views
to bring down his bandmates
so leaving is the only way he can speak
freely
yeah i've been following this for a
while when he first tweeted about andy
now and even
the way andy know is introduced like on
this show that he's a right-wing crazy
person
i don't know where that came from he's
actually a very brave journalist that i
believe is in the hospital right now
and he has been reporting the only
person that's been reporting about
antifa in portland
for the past two years and i i you know
the
antifa is so bad over there the national
guard was sent in to try and help kept
portland under control they had an
autonomous zone
where people were getting killed and
raped and it had to be disbanded like
he's just reporting and it's very
strange to me that he's been turned into
someone that could make
someone in mumford and sons leave the
band he his statement is really
fascinating and
i thought it was really well done he was
saying just because you're calling out
hypocrisy on the left doesn't make you a
you know right-wing extremist as well
okay so obviously well said meghan
mccain right there it's nice to see
someone
actually defending something close to
honesty and truth and everything else
i don't know that andy noah is in the
hospital right now but i will tell you
this he was invited to my
birthday party this weekend and i was
actually willing to fly him out here
but he wanted to rest up because he does
have injuries related
to some of his reporting and what antifa
is doing to him okay that is a fact that
is out of his
mouth okay the idea that joy behar would
call him a
far right wing pundit now far right wing
pundit when you say far right we can
find it what what is that implication
the implication is racist right like
number one it's racist
it's usually homophobic now andy happens
to be gay but
i guess you could be a gay homophobe
these days if you're if you're not a
leftist
um it's that you are against the other
right your prejudice i don't even know
it doesn't really mean anything at this
point it just
in essence what joy behar is saying is
evil right she's saying
evil person andy no now andy noe has
been under attack
physical assault and has been violently
attacked by people
many many times joy behar doesn't seem
to care about that
now i'll give joy the benefit of the
doubt the benefit of that would be that
joy behar doesn't know what she's
talking about and she's just reading a
script
that they put in front of her right she
was obviously reading off a teleprompter
for that intro so joy i will go out of
my way here
to give you the benefit of the doubt and
perhaps you will apologize for reading
the lies that your producer put in front
of you
that will be uh what i will do for you
here joy in
in the name of the fact that you were
once a decent liberal but this is
this is absolutely disgusting now it
would be far more fair
for me to say that joy behar is a far
left lunatic she is a far lefty she
wants the government
to do absolutely everything she thinks
that everyone who is against her is a
bigot and a racist
and a homophobe and i would also argue
that at that point once you've accepted
those things you're pretty much a
lunatic
okay and you can get joy to take almost
any position on anything depending on
what trump believes so you may remember
back a few months ago i think we covered
it
when uh who who is the the white
supremacist who's the leader of the
alt-right remember that guy
richard spencer remember that guy
richard spencer i can't even remember
his name because
these people are irrelevant but at one
point during the the presidential
campaign
richard spencer said he was no longer
gonna
support donald trump and joy behar
brought that up on the view
and the audience applauded so they were
applauding joy was instigating the
audience to applaud for the white
supremacists because at least the white
supremacist is against trump
these people are all completely
bananas they're a combination of like
compulsive chronic liars
and just off the rockers bananas nuts